>>RGUABLY THE MOST
UNFORGETTABLE MONTE
> LITERALLY IMPOSSI
EXTRAORDINARY.
BUT SOMEHOW WE'RE WA
ITRO
YOU HAVE TO NET ER
BE SHOOFF,
NEVER FAIL, NEVER,VE
WATCH
THAT PE WIE US.LF INTO K S
>> AH, YES, THE PERPETUADOUBLE
STANDARDS.
A FERRERA WITH RAW
STINSPIRATIONA
E IMPOSSIBLE E HELD
WIONG INTO
R AFTEE "GOLDEN " WHERE "BARBIER
FERRERA HEREN L.A.LK  BARBIE'S
MI OSCARTROVERFERR
PRRA THANK YOU.
>> HOW SURPRISEDE YOU MPTHATUE
SECRBIE" WHICH
>> IT WAS IN HOW AFU
HIT THENCES AND WHAT
RESPONRE
I KNOW TSTD RIEFTER ANININE
BE EXTRAORDINARY, BUW
WE'RE YS DOING IT WRG.
I KNOW THAI WAS JUST BLOWNAWAY,
EXCITED, YOU KNOW, THAT --
IT'S THE "BARBIEVIE THO
ONE ASFOR,
THOUGHT WE NEEDED, KNOW.
>>IND OF
SERIOUSLY FEMINIST. YES.
NBELIEVT.THEY THOUGHT IT WAS G
ANOTHER TELLING OF SF  WITH.
>> YD IT COULD HAVE BEEN THAT, U
KNOW, IT VERY AVE
GHN
AND  PROBAHAVE MADE  MON ANDFUL.
BUWHRETA AND HER
ID WITH THE SCPTRETA AS THE DIR
EAWORLD,
GENERO, ASN WOMAN,KNOWET A TRDOD
THENO MEETS ADULT, , INSECUREVI
LING T, , SO  THINGS TO SMA DIFT
PEOPLEIT WAS SO
FEEL LIK HAD AN Y.AT -
THAT WAY INDEPENDENT OF BEING E
AS A WOMANN D.
>> WE PLAYED A LITTLE BI SPEECH.
WHAT WOULD YOUTHE  STANDOUT
MESSAG WANTED
MAYBNOW WANT EVE TO GET O YOUNGN
I ANTHAT'S THETHER PIECE
OF THE GENEROSITY OFIS
TANDH DI ONLY
E EY A FOITO T S JOURNEY, TO TH
ABOUT FEMININITY AND THI
MASCULINT NEOUT
FOR THIS CHARACTER THAANGOSLING
IT WAS SO AMG TO
I DO FEEL LIKEHEESS
EP
R ME JUST
FOR  ALLENE E OF THESE BOXES,
LITERAL AND
BMORE THA AND
WE KEEP OURSELS IN.
>> SOME CONTROVERS
APATLM
ANCOMEDI H
, YOU KNOW, THF THE AC
AWTHE
REEGOR
THAD OAL
SCENAI T
IT'S INSTIO
?
Y I'M N WRITER
DOT  ANDE INS AND OUTS OF THINTO
GRETA GOT HER HANDS,O AT ANYONE
ANYTHING TGRET IF ANYTIS IP ANCS
ACLE
TOWARD CXCITIN
GROUNDBREAKINGRY ANDCHARACTER.
ITHOLLY AN
AL.
AND I THIN ISH HTH THAT THE ITEM
KNOW TOLD MARK RONSON, THE
BE AE E" AND
DID AMERICA FERRERS WOO VERYQUE
CUAL IMPACT AND REALULND INDIVLN
HAVE.
SOEEINSPIRING, IT'S TY, IT'SEMA
RULES THT BREA.
THINK THAT IT WAS -
WAS THATIDESMAIDS" MOMENT
WHERE BEFORE THAT THERE WA
UNSPOKENCCOMEN
WEREN'T FUNNY AN WOMEN'S VIES CF
IT WAS A MOVIE ABOUT WOMEN MEN
OTHER
PE, AND ITCOULDN'T TRAVEL AND C
MAKE MONEY.
I DO FEEL LIKE THERE WAS ABEFORR
"BRIDESMAIDS."
'S
THE SCRIPT W WERE NGTHE MO GNG .
IT'SOI ABOUT OPENG
PEOPLE'S IDEAS
POSSN  AND
WHAT WE'RE CAPABLE
GIRL'S
SELL.
>> YES, E
STORIES.
EW LIF
TO BE TOM S.
YOU KNOW, I GREW UP PUTTING
MYSELF IN
CHILD.
LIKE OUR CANE  OF COURSE PEOPLEL
NDN SEE THEMSELVES IN CH OTHER.
A CHOICE TE LE.
VALUINHO SAN